unos pocos cientos para celebrar una
anexión aprobada presuntamente por una
mayoría abrumadora la plaza principal
del lugar fue el sitio escogido para
festejar la incorporación de este y
otros tres territorios ucranianos a la
federación de Rusia
[Música]
finalmente somos parte de Rusia la
victoria será nuestra y todo Estará
abierto
todos nuestros deseos serán realidad
una pancarta gigante recuerda quién
decidirá sus destinos con Rusia para
siempre
sabes el evento de hoy tiene un
significado mundial
algo que nuestra gente nuestra región se
ha ganado con su sangre
Ucrania no quedó de brazos cruzados ante
la anexión de un 15% de su territorio
nacional por parte de Moscú El
presidente voladimir zelenski firmó una
petición para unirse en un proceso
acelerado a la organización del tratado
del Atlántico Norte una iniciativa
respaldada por buena parte de la
ciudadanía que busca un escudo de
protección en tiempos de crisis
de todos modos es algo bueno porque esto
en primer demuestra que el comandante en
jefe entiende de qué lado de la frontera
está nuestro futuro en segundo lugar es
mejor avanzar hacia el mundo civilizado
si esto al menos nos da armas y apoyo
político Entonces porque no
que creo que si eso significa que mi
familia estará a salvo mi país estará a
salvo y podré viajar a salvo a ver a mis
familiares en la región de sapurilla y
la otan nos protegerá de esta manera
Entonces sí la otan no guardó silencio
su secretario general James totelberg
calificó la apropiación de las cuatro
regiones ucranianas por parte de Rusia
como la escalada más grave que se ha
vivido desde el inicio de la invasión
sin embargo un eventual adhesión de
Ucrania la alianza militar trasatlántica
sigue siendo una posibilidad remota para
lograrlo se requeriría el consenso de
los 30 miembros que la componen